hey guys I'm Ryan right hi there I'm
Veronica today we're checking out the
honest trailer the truthful trailer to
Ty story part you know before we begin
I'm gonna start a fundraiser a
Kickstarter campaign for a dramatic
retelling of Toy Story okay like appear
here I'll give you some of it right now
okay you or a toy you're not the real
thing you're an action figure you are a
child's plaything I'm going to buzz buzz
buzz you are a sad strange little man
farewell yeah well good riddance you
loony what he has a drinking problem in
my interpretation
in the studio that single-handedly
stopped Disney for making more terrible
sequels to the Emperor's New Groove
comes the animated classic that forced
every 2d animator to learn how to use a
computer or to get a new job Toy Story
secured that inspired an epic one of
original Pixar movies they were so good
we all gave them a pass for cars to head
ready for the classic children's new
that's all about jealousy broken dreams
and the existential thread that you were
warming a live your purpose and be
replaced by someone newer and better you
know fancy fix our stuff return to a
simpler time when kids only had toys and
their imaginations to play with for a
movie that would be all of that a boy in
his iPad if it came out today and
witness the first ever fully computer
animated feature that looks pretty good
considering we came at the same year as
Windows 95 point the mouse of the start
button bottom left and click on
computing watch as these toys come to
life in a secret society that's just as
boring and fun as our own Tuesday
night's plastic corrosion awareness
meeting was often a big success notice
by now seriously we're not even trying
to be discreet
we need to spaz like a hundred houses
someone would have seen him with rudy'
an erotic weak egotistical control freak
you stay away
Oh shun movie but when the roof ever toy
buzz lightyear appears will attempt to
further his in a jealous with land
adventure affinity between the sad
strange men are a sad strange little man
and a delusional Taiwanese spaceman and
shoots first and asks questions later I
was at my laser from stun to kill God
right right yeah everybody what attacks
we can play come to death because he's
trying to kill him
scape the clutches of C the only person
who's ever successfully used a claw
machine twice a creepily rendered young
boy which nineties computers clearly
weren't ready for great justice child
villain whose biggest crimes are
tinkering the toys he didn't know her
alive and acting up to get the attention
of his drug daddy
it's taught a lesson so cruel it will
undoubtedly starting for life
so today nice - that's messed up so get
ready to go to infinity and beyond with
the animated classic you end up watching
countless more times with your own kids
one day causing you to bring up
existential questions or can't help but
ask why can't we die our toys born when
do they become sentient can they have
kids - sex - is killed do all the toys
initially have the same mental the
philosophical break Dennis was it buzzes
no it to being in space
what isn't woody of knowledge of his
ground game unique slavery for to which
to us can talk in which words can since
tools can with the binoculars can and he
doesn't even allow his enemies my
realize it's super illegal to have a
baby Brian Tracy huh everybody was that
wears Eddie's dad know this he's got a
one-year-old so he must have been around
recently didn't run out of them did he
die is any so attached to we because
it's the last thing is that game waiting
so hurry boy boy
you watch for three and that's a wrap
man this job is antic hey everybody who
watch the meltdown some gold records and
rabbits go for tacos my treat
I'm still the villain story Vin Diesel
in consumable rags choking hazards real
minions sip fishes of both Pete left now
is that a toy whoa dog silver John have
many from other babies toy Hanks and
Tory story well it's pretty much what it
is be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers that was all true ya know that
when it makes me want to watch Toy Story
I still a lot of Toy Story from it what
these little cartoon movies are made for
kids but they're always created by
adults like the other side of the adult
understanding the emotional aspect I
love Toy Story a lot but there are
things they pointed out that I do think
about like how jealous and angry and
controlling thought about that yeah like
how Woody is just like kind of a dick to
people buzz comes in he's like wants to
be the leader you know and he's more of
a leader than Woody is and what he just
wants to be like the leader but he kind
of behaves like a dictator at times like
he's just so bossy and [ __ ] and he just
tells people to shut up it is true how
what he is character that his character
does have done I know what he's really
likable they cut out all the likable
stuff that's trailer but what he's very
[ __ ] lovable yeah and then another
question was this likes to Toy Story 2
is that woody you find out has this
whole like character history with the
woody a doll and who what he was on
television but then he doesn't remember
any of it yet buzz has all these
memories of Star Command and all this
stuff so that didn't make sense
that's just a nitpicky thing but
whatever how Andy's dad is not around
that is like the all-time question that
I myself and I know a lot of other
people that and I love how they
capitalize off of that joking on how
Andy's tens just never mentioned or seen
and yet they have like a one-year-old
child you don't so it's like the dad
must have been around recently and
Joey's attached to toys because of what
of him being abandoned it's a really
dark humor well what if it was what if
he was just that work all the time
they went moving and he wasn't there
with them when they went movie they were
probably moving cuz of a divorce maybe
he had to stay by because he had his own
business and he was based in that area
so they left or he got caught cheating
with a Taiwanese hooker I think mine
sounds more probably like he's in jail
yeah yeah and he was like a pervert dad
so he was like huh had this all is
called woody yeah yeah I know it's a
sick it's not me it's the writing and
the other thing that I really thought it
was like Sid being scarred like I know
Sid was a dick oh my god but he didn't
know the toys weren't alive he was just
doing what he wanted to do with toys
yeah he wasn't you don't see him being a
dick to like people all the time and
stuff but then like the toy comes to
life and they like what he comes to life
and I always felt very scared and yeah
it's sad for him because no one's gonna
[ __ ] believe him and now he's is
scarred I would love to see like a
really dark spin off of Sid when he's
like in his 30s and he's trying to prove
theories about toys being alive and he
you know he's like works at a university
sure he would be a mass murderer
actually or he just killed himself don't
blame me it's the writing anyway guys
thanks for saying that was out if you
need to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out
Veronica's channel which has a lot of
acoustic covers on there and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine or if we get more followers we
can get product
no you were looking at me Colten
D'Agostino
hey Ryan just thought I would get this
shout out thing a shot
longtime subscriber and loved the videos
my question is there ever going to be a
real rejects fan meetup or like a movie
review screening also I would love the
chance to do a reaction with you okay
I'll ask will there be yeah I'll answer
all three questions yes there will be a
fan meetup and then when more people in
California [ __ ] existent subscribe to
this channel speak up and I'll see if we
could do a fan meetup and anyone from
other states are welcome to move your
review screening that would be fun to do
I was thinking we could go to like like
a porn house catch the latest porn flick
that the audience gets to watch this oh
yeah point eaters still yeah where we've
been there before
Romero's my movie you got jealous you
ran out of the theater you started
yelling at me saying why'd you bring me
to this I said I'm not too surprised it
just completely blocked out of my memory
yeah this is why people say you deserve
better on the comment box oh also a
chance to do a reaction with you sure if
you live in California you're more than
welcome to come by Colton so I'm gonna
introduce you my house you're gonna be
the fan that murders me thank you thank
you
the obsessed man you don't put that into
the universe no I'm telling you I died I
wanted to be because a fan got so
obsessed with me kill me no you didn't
want sure knock on wood that that
happens yeah that [ __ ] happens
oh that [ __ ] happens that they said that
should happen why well we would be going
down two different conversations it
shouldn't okay Colton yeah